art as it has been said is often
subjective whether it's a sculpture an
oil painting from the renaissance a
renowned work of literature a digitally
drawn web comic or an insightful
animated youtube video about scp
foundation lore the deeper meaning
behind a piece of art can often change
depending on the individual observing it
sometimes an artist intentionally makes
the message of their artwork clear
hoping to have its meaning be
unmistakable to any and all that might
see it other times such a meaning can be
more ambiguous harder to decipher
without some serious thought but either
way art is an important way that human
beings interpret the world around us it
can be a reflection of emotions
experiences history and every new
creation is as legitimate a piece of art
as the last but even with that being
said there may be no piece of art that
is a better reflection of the world
around us than scp-804
or to use its alternative title the
world without man as you might have
already guessed scp-804
is an art installation or at the very
least is what's left of an art
installation the piece itself which was
unveiled in alaska was created by a
group of artists known by the name
inelmat
a finnish phrase which translates to
dreams of a better world in english a
fitting highly appropriate name for a
group that created scp-804
given the subject of the piece all that
remains of the artwork itself is a
portion of a once larger statue sculpted
to resemble the shape of a globe
following extensive examination by the
scp foundation's researchers this globe
has been determined to be most likely a
recreation of our very own planet earth
originally this globe was a large clear
model of earth that also featured a
number of smaller globes and video
equipment inside of it it appears then
that this art installation may have been
intended to function as a projector of
sorts displaying varying images of
scenes from around the world
these images would have primarily
focused on deserted and run-down areas
of human society such as abandoned
buildings and decaying landmarks the art
piece seems to have depicted how even
when we reshape our world and build
cities we can damage the planet's
fragile ecosystem this is especially
prevalent when things we build are then
later left empty buildings rotting away
structures neglected to waste this mass
destruction of nature all in vain these
images would then have been contrasted
with projections that show parts of the
natural world that have yet to be
touched by human beings serene beautiful
places like the corners of the amazon
rainforest or the deepest stretches of
our oceans the message of the piece well
we can only speculate but it seems as if
it played a role in highlighting the
difference between the modern and
natural world so what could be so
important about one leftover piece of a
statue how about this when it was first
unveiled scp-804 was able to produce a
massive destructive force one in which
plenty of people were present to witness
the foundation has uncovered a number of
documents about world without man from
the artist's website when they stepped
in to clear up what happened after
scp-804
was revealed among those present when
the piece was displayed were an audience
of prominent environmental activists who
were well known throughout the world for
their efforts to alert people to the
threats facing our environment and would
likely be the ones that the message of
world without man would resonate with
the most of course we doubt that the scp
foundation is all that interested in the
artistic value of
scp-804 or its message of protecting the
environment for that matter what
happened next was probably more likely
to be what caught their interest from
the moment it was activated
scp-804 is destructive properties were
unleashed and it is still unclear if
this was intentional or not had the
members of inel matpar mashtamal mashta
plan to unfurl chaos at the revealing of
their masterpiece or was world without
man sabotaged by someone who disagreed
with its deeper meaning it is hard to
say
the only thing that the foundation knows
for certain is that no one survived
anyone present during the incident was
killed where they stood and those
responsible for creating scp-804
either went into hiding or perished
themselves when activated the smaller
globes within
scp-804's larger one began to rotate
causing the display of its destructive
and anomalous properties the sculpture
itself causes any man-made devices or
artifacts within a 100 meter radius to
stop working everything from phones and
tablets to clothing plastic buildings
and even synthetic chemical compounds
will begin to deteriorate decay and even
disintegrate if something is more
advanced than a sharpened stick of wood
scp-804 can destroy it the longer world
without man remains active the wider its
area of effect and the stronger its
destructive power will be however its
ability to destroy any man-made object
is always strongest closer to the source
right next to the globe of the sculpture
sounds pretty inconvenient to be
subjected to losing your clothes and
personal belongings if you stand too
close but still harmless right wrong
scp-804 also has an adverse destructive
effect on human beings tissue cells will
also deteriorate in the same way if they
are within the radius of world without
man however this happens much slower
than when the sculpture disintegrates
man-made matter people standing too
close will be painfully and
excruciatingly broken down cell by cell
a victim of
scp-804 will gradually lose body mass
bit by bit until only their skeleton
remains but it does not stop there the
effects of the anomalous art piece will
continue even after death dissolving
bone organs muscle and marrow into their
most basic atomic components until truly
nothing remains interestingly there are
ways to survive an encounter with the
anomalous effects of scp-804
the first is to well not be a human
being anything non-human including all
forms of animal and plant life will be
left unharmed by the sculpture so if you
can somehow think of a quick way to
transform yourself into a bird or a
hydrangea you would manage to escape
unscathed in theory at least speaking of
escaping though even if you were caught
in
scp-804's area of effect there is a
chance you could still survive if you
got far enough away before your entire
body was turned to dust though drastic
it is possible to recover from world
without man's human tissue damage given
the proper circumstances and volume of
medical care during the scp foundation's
testing those who have survived have
suffered symptoms similar to those of
extreme and prolonged starvation
creating a sculpture that sends out a
shock wave capable of destroying all
man-made materials and any human beings
within 100 meters of its source is
certainly one hell of a way to get the
deeper message of your artwork across
but that might have you thinking if
scp-804
is a piece of art and it was created by
the members of an art collective then
isn't world without man also technically
man-made and you would be correct in
thinking that through prolonged testing
of the device the scp foundation has
determined that scp-804
is not immune to its own destructive
effects since its first activation
and over the course of the foundation's
rigorous examination of it the
sculpture's capabilities have become
impaired however this does not make it
any less dangerous if someone was
somehow able to repair
scp-804 perhaps reunited with the statue
it was originally a part of then the
threat it would pose to the modern world
would be astronomical how bad would the
damage be well let's put it this way if
scp-804 was able to remain fully active
without suffering its own effects then
this anomalous artwork could easily wipe
any and all traces of humanity from the
face of planet earth in a matter of
weeks you could be forgiven for thinking
that destroying man-made artifacts and
disintegrating human tissue was the
worst that
scp-804 can do but you would be wrong
yet again the foundation's top
researchers have theorized that world
without man also possess some form of
memetic effect that
scp-804 is able to mentally influence
people possibly creating a compulsion
among those who view it however they are
still uncertain of this and testing is
currently focused on if this effect has
also been weakened by
scp-804's gradual decay but back to when
this destructive piece of art was first
discovered unmet paramash the mailmaster
had unveiled world without man at an art
show in alaska around five minutes after
scp-804 initially activated a nearby
remote town in northern alaska was the
first to feel the effects the residents
were panicked calling for emergency
services after all wouldn't you be
afraid if you realized that you were
starting to disintegrate along with your
home and all of your possessions
unfortunately the town was too remote of
a location for anyone to properly
respond a single light aircraft was the
first on the scene and the pilot
witnessed firsthand as the entire town
was rapidly wiped out by the time the
foundation heard about the situation and
dispatched its agents to the location
there was nothing left not one home nor
any living person
scp-804 had been active for almost eight
straight hours and the nearby alaskan
town had been wiped clean of any and all
traces of human civilization the
foundation's agents traced the epicenter
of scp-804's destructive effect back to
where it had been unveiled only to
discover that survivors from the nearby
town had gathered around what was left
of the sculpture many of them were
already suffering from hypothermia as
well as being severely affected by the
device in other ways somehow these
survivors were being compelled to
approach
scp-804 and push the globe within to
reactivate its effect if one died
another would step forward from the
group to take their place those around
the sculpture would cheer and encourage
them to maintain the anomalous artwork
praising them for keeping it running
despite what
scp-804 was doing to them
under the orders of an 05 council member
the foundation's agents on site opened
fire on the crowd their bullets
disintegrating from the statue's effect
but still managing to cause lethal
wounds as the globe stopped spinning the
effects of scp-804 ended and the agents
were able to move in and secure the
sculpture many of the survivors then
opted to lie down in the snow letting
their injuries and the cold kill them
any that were arrested by the foundation
refused to respond to questioning given
that any foundation facility would be
man-made in nature it was decided that
scp-804 would be best left where it was
allowing the alaskan cold to freeze its
machinery a handful of foundation guards
were left on site as well just in case
anyone decided to come looking for world
without man and try to reactivate the
anomalous piece of art additionally the
foundation wanted the remains of the
device kept away from their facilities
until they could figure out if or how it
had compelled people to keep it active
dr johannes sorts of the scp foundation
investigated the memetic properties of
scp-804
and according to his findings there is
nothing especially virulent or dangerous
about
scp-804's mimetic properties only a few
select personality types have any desire
to reactivate the device we've been
looking at this all wrong there is no
magical compulsion that could drive so
many people to destroy themselves there
does not need to be the artist and
activist group inelmat parmasta
malmashta had created a device capable
of wiping out all traces of human life
on earth it could turn buildings and
people to dust making any that were left
keeping it spinning no matter if it
killed them it was made to represent an
ideal the cure for the planet from the
disease of humanity but why would these
activists unleash it on a town full of
innocent people if they knew this
machine had the potential to wipe out
all human life on earth why activate it
killing themselves too
the answer is simple because
they wanted to
they intended to send a message but the
real question is are we smart enough to
listen to it now go check out
scp-2317 the devourer of worlds a door
to another world and scp-xk class
end-of-the-world scenarios explain for
more anomalies that could bring humanity
to its knees